I really wonder if it really went down
that way is that how Michael Jackson
taught his kids to moonwalk it is just
one of the many cool moments from the
new lifetime movie about his life and
nischelle Turner went behind the scenes
with the man who is playing the King of
Pop Make A Wish I'm supposed to tell I
wish we could go back home to Neverland
we can't ever go back to Neverland that
lease been contaminated by evil who is
the man cast to play Michael
his name is Navi the Trinidad native
says that for 17 years he was hired by
Jackson himself to work as his body
double
the 40-something performer has had
numerous plastic surgery operations
changing his nose cheekbones and chin
just to look more like the King of Pop
it's shocking how similar you look to
him I used to work for him as a decoy
and I performed at his birthday parties
and when he went through the trials I
stood outside the courthouse and I stood
there with a sign saying smooth another
criminal and to me it was important that
I wanted Michael to know that I believe
in him Michael Jackson searching for
Neverland focuses on the last three
years of MJ's life as told through the
eyes of his two bodyguards one family
incident you'll see is blanket
mischievously pressing one of the panic
buttons the security team had placed
throughout the house the armed guards
come running blanket that's not funny
get over here everybody time for school
I thought about owning the gun once then
I realized probably too many people
don't want to shoot have you spoken to
the family or the kids about about this
film I have spoken to the family in the
past but I haven't spoken to them about
this project but you know I believe that
when this project is out they will know
itself a fair and true portrayal Paris
Jackson has been invited to the set but
is yet to come check out the biopic
which is based on the best-selling book
remember the time nabis goal is to give
an authentic performance out of respect
to Michael himself if he knew Michael
Jackson he would onto the phone and
loved on to the phone he was so
disconnected against his own will I
stood with him in a hotel room and
looked down at fans that were gathering
and he would sometimes put on the
outfits and disguises and go out there
because he would send pizza in the
middle of the night and because they
were cold and you know he loved his fans
when you're done with this will you go
back to impersonating him or do you feel
like you will leave that chapter in the
past of your life I'm going back to pick
up my glove put on my shoes and get back
on say
[Music]